françoise hardy a toujours aimé les duos
avoue que l'on retrouve dans son nouvel
album une parenthèse paru chez virgin un
album dans lequel elle est accompagnée
s'il vous plaît d'alain souchon henri
salvador bachelot y alain delon et
jacques dutronc
l'album est sorti le 27 novembre
quand on connaît la passion de françoise
hardy pour l'astrologie on se dit que ce
n'est sûrement pas une date choisie au
hasard dans un journal intime très
nostalgique elle évoque le temps qui
passe les amis qui disparaissent mais
aussi la rédemption par la grande
musique à le concerto numéro 2 pour
piano de rachmaninov
ne sachant pas du tout l aimant la seule
chose qui m'intéressait c'était la
chanson mon premier disque est sorti à
ce moment là et j'ai tout de suite été
accaparées par le succès
excessif il méritait des émeutes sur et
qui s'en est suivi je l'entends de temps
en temps j'ai beaucoup de mal à
l'entendre je dis arrêtez ça tout mais
je l'aimais bien les ports qu'à l'époque
j'en étais très contente j'étais très
heureux
là une école qui me paraît très très au
dessus des autres surtout parce que elle
va plus loin elle est allée elle est
plus intelligente et elle n'avance rien
qu'ils ne soient connectés aux réalités
du système solaire c'est l'astrologie
dit conditionna liste tout se passerait
comme si à la naissance
le système nerveux du du nouveau-né
garderait fixerait le l'empreinte de des
rythmes du système solaire tels qu'ils
sont à ce moment précis on ne sait pas
trop en réalité ce que quelqu'un fait de
son ciel de naissance qui est un
conditionnement en rapport avec tous les
autres conditionnement qui sont ceux
d'un être humain
le conditionnement génétique le
conditionnement socioculturel affectif
etc
la vie est faite de bons sauts qui se
joue à cannes
[Musique]
la vie est faite de morceaux qui ne se
joignent pas la moselle brown
mais la mélancolie c'est sûr que ça fait
partie de ma personnalité que toutes les
chansons que j'ai chanté tout au long de
mon parcours sont son mélancolique du
simple fait d'ailleurs que ce qui
importe le plus pour moi c'est la
mélodie et que une mélodie nebel à mes
oreilles que quand elle a une dimension
de tristesse et de mélancolie
à partir du moment où on est conscient
du tragique de la condition humaine
et comment ne pas en être conscient on
est conscient que tout ce qu'on aime
dans la vie et les gens qu'on aime tout
cela va s'arrêter
tôt ou tard je que comment ne pas être
mélancolique il ya une chanson de
benjamin biolay qui s'appelle des
lendemains qui chantent et qui termine
l'album cette chanson elle me touche
particulièrement parce que justement la
manière dont il a écrit le texte est
superbe et la mélodie qui est très
mélancolique justement pour moi ce sont
des lendemains qui chantent et qui
n'arriveront jamais
[Musique]
s'il nous faut choisir qu'un concerto je
choisis le concerto numéro 2 de
rachmaninov je le trouve absolument
déchirant bouleversant beau de bout en
bout avec des thèmes mélodiques de bout
en bout et si vous voulez moi moi j'aime
la musique
eux qui subliment une souffrance de
telle façon que finalement ça élève
[Musique]
oh
vous savez il ya certaines musiques qui
exprime la douleur la souffrance est qui
et qui vous plombe
or cette musique là c'est comme si elle
justifiait toute cette souffrance quoi
c'est parce que au fur et à mesure on
monte au ciel enfin moi ça me ça me fait
monter au ciel
trouver
la timidité vient du fait qu'on se sent
très en dessous mais papa physiquement
seulement j'ai vu récemment des photos
de moi qui ont été faites quand j'étais
plus jeune j'étais évidemment très très
complexée je vois les photos je me dis
vraiment quel dommage quelle perte de
temps et d'énergie d'avoir été autant
complexé alors que j'étais pas trop mal
toutes les situations qui consiste à
chanter une chanson à la télévision mais
même en playback de toute façon je ne
fais que ça sont des situations qui me
met sens dessus dessous c'est une
question de traque un là j'aime pas ça
du tout du tout du tout c'est vrai que
plus je suis cash et moi moi on le voit
et mieux je me sens quand j'étais petite
fille je j'essayais de me mettre au
dernier rang de la classe j'avais qu'une
peur c'est que le professeur me disent
mon nom pour que je récite la leçon
j'avais l'impression de pas savoir et
c'est toujours été parfois jeudi de mon
fils thomas qu'il est qu'il est beaucoup
plus gentil que ses parents ou mais en
réalité ce que je veux dire c'est qu'il
est plus ouvert et ça va un peu ensemble
c'est vrai que quelqu'un comme jacques
ou comme moi on a on a du mal à aller
vers les gens on a du mal quand on est
sollicité à répondre oui
alors que thomas est beaucoup plus
réceptif et
naturellement accueillant je dirais
ainsi comme
[Musique]